[Musique]
bienvenue chez guillaume boulanger
depuis 17 ans un professionnel tombé
dedans quand il était petit poucet
j'ai fait du pain à la cantine de mon
école et ça ne m'a vraiment permis de
découvrir le pain et j'ai toujours voulu
faire la boulangerie depuis notre
artisans fabriquent toujours du bon pain
et des galettes aussi 100% maison 100%
100% maison ça veut dire que tout est
fabriqué sur place ce soit la pâte
feuilletée comme la crème d'amande tout
est fabriqué sur place et tout est
terminé ici il n'ya pas de process
industriels laon chic tu la galette sur
le côté pour ne pas qu'elles s'ouvrent
aux côtés de guillaume hily à damien
fabriqués maison c'est important une
marque de respect
pour nous c'est vraiment
qualitative de faire du 100% maison pour
ne pas tricher avec la clientèle
et pour couronner le tout des fèves aux
couleurs locales sont glissés dans les
précieuses galettes nos qu'on peut
retrouver voilà les écluses de faille
aux loges à l'usiné électrique la
fontaine 5 comme
l'église aussi en plus qui vient d'être
restaurée elles sont décorés à la main
et je trouvais que sakho des vaches ou
bien avec notre politique en fait de
faire nous-mêmes déjà tout ce qu'on fait
maison je trouvais que ça collait plutôt
bien avec notre politique
l'an passé à la même époque guillaume à
fabriquer pas moins de 900 galette un
nombre qu'il devrait pouvoir égaler
cette année